[Musik]
hollywood wasser hat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft so herzlich willkommen
beim orads 5 minuten kochen und backen
auf geringem bildungsniveau geringes
bildungsniveau heißt das thema also habe
ich hier bin ich eingeladen bin daher
vorstellt das ist ein freund von mir
zumindest behauptet das normalerweise
kommt nur zum essen her oder hilfen auf
der baustelle aber nicht mal ein brett
das ist aber heute hilft man backen weil
du hast schon einmal in deinem leben
richtig cooles spritzgebäck gemacht der
schmeckt einfach genial
ja das habe ich mir ein wenig sorgen
gemacht und mir und da alles kann auch
schon probiert da findet das wahnsinnig
gut und freue mich drauf bin ich ja auch
gerade mit ihrem bug man was zu wenig
ordnung ist so schön
auf jeden fall anschauen das jetzt
machen ganz ganz einfach und fangen an
den zutaten oder das rezept brauchen wir
100 gramm nougat das sind zwar 300 aber
die 100 gramm
die anderen 100 kann die erst mal
zwischendurch dann haben wir 200 gramm
weiche butter 70 gramm puderzucker eine
prise salz dann einen halben teelöffel
zimt ein glückliches eigelb dann ein
teelöffel vanille extrakt 50 gramm
gemahlene nüsse buttermilch 50
milliliter und 300 gramm weizenmehl ganz
normal 40
als allererstes wird der juni mit mir
zusammen - schmelzen mit der polizei
genau okay dann sag' sagt volle bus ist
normal dass da hier gut 3
erst mal die null grad aber mit
rassismus ist näher was das geht schon
gehen ich glaube dass verbrennt doch das
nein nein diesmal die haselnüsse mir
darunter so lange bis alle schmilzt die
hasel malen genau das hast du schon mal
machen wir halt jetzt wissen wir wie es
geht im netz machen ist ein problem ja
alles kriegst du hin wenn jeder
[Musik]
was machen wir als nächstes reicht es
noch trennen ja und zwar der alten
teilweise nachtrennen schleicht und zwar
das geht ganz einfach hier sagt siehst
du das so jetzt haben wir aus dieser aus
der butter und haben wir jetzt eine
butter nougat creme gemacht
währenddessen der bühne jetzt rum
gerührt hat wir haben auch schon diese
hasen formalen danach mal hier
das eigelb jetzt immer alles das hier
und tun alles in einen topf und machen
die homogene masse daraus geworden
jetzt sind wir das eigelb und das machen
wir es da rein sagt jetzt nehmen wir
dieses not und so war auch da rein ja
nur was kann man auch daran machen den
rückgang gute sogar schuldig schuldig
aber jetzt gucke nicht gewinnt genau das
geld darf nichts zu gewinnen weil sie
nur ganz schön warm ist nicht als er
nach einem spiel drin hat und jetzt
machen wir machen die hase ist ja auch
mit rein und jetzt wenn man die anderen
zutaten natürlich auch mit rein einen
moment wenig helfen und zwar hier haben
wir hier haben wir sind und salz gott
erhalten
hier machen wir puderzucker mit rein
nein nummer 22 bis 405 weil ich nicht
glücklich ist wann immer ein esslöffel
einen extrakt heute gehts richtig
schnell
egal ob man längst da kann man hier zu
viel machen
hast du schon mal ich kann mir schon
gedacht mein okay aber ich lasse mir das
von der bereitschaft prinz und sein kopf
runter und dann musst du langsam auf
erster stufe anfang auf eine stufe mit
schon auf zwei wochen das erste studio
sie ist die erste stufe langsam bis sie
das vom kunden hat zu einer heterogenen
masse was pedro wie normal verschließt
es wieder
und jetzt hat sie es verboten jetzt
merke schon der ich da ist der teufel
los
wir haben auch gestern genau wir machen
also die brauchst du aber nur wenn der
teig ist ja der musste durch die presse
also butter milch drauf war mit der
trick ist natürlich bringt fotos milch
beim ging nichts mehr
damit nicht genug auch nicht durch die
buttermilch aber du schöne schütze der
sich der druck war ein
und derzeit der muss so leicht wie soll
ich sagen der teig darf nicht zu flüssig
sein weil sonst nachher über die spricht
spritzgebäck presse benutzen was
spritzgebäck was für ein cooler namen
nach irgendwie spritzgebäck resolution
wird es alles raus laufen zu halten
fertig sein wenn nicht können wir nicht
mal presse und deswegen muss es eine so
zwischendrin ungefähr so wie silikon
richtig ich muss mein homogene negative
rate für die nach machen aber herrschen
die kamera aus ist okay jetzt war doch
ein bisschen futter mich rein ich habe
gemerkt es ist noch ein bisschen zu
trocken würde ich sagen bin ich zu dick
[Musik]
so wie es übrigens auch erst wird der
teig so ein bisschen foto menschen ein
bisschen mehr rein geben jetzt gucken
mal kurz bin ich glaube er ist in
ordnung
der schilder simic wir müsste auch der
muster auch standfest sein hass war
probiert wie schmeckt eigentlich
[Musik]
obwohl salzig ich habe einen zweifel
genommen
[Musik]
falls ja was jetzt haben sind wirklich
genommen so klein ich cool
jetzt kommt der nächste schritt und zwar
die gehweg presse in dem gepäck besser
kennt wahrscheinlich jeder von euch
meistens aus kunststoff weniger
empfehlen kann ist aus edelstahl
weil da kann die kühle genug druck
aufbauen ohne dass es den kaputt geht
mit der zeit
so jetzt müssen wir mal verstehen wie
das ding funktioniert
und jetzt nehmen wir das ding dankeschön
kann auf den teig einfüllen
er ist so richtig so ein bisschen
verrutscht auch runter das ist die
butter richtig cool
also sitzt und sowas ohne gepäck presse
ist was ganz cooles und das kriegt auch
wirklich jeder hinter und tolles geht
mag ich schwarz versicherungen kabine in
dem silikon spritzigen effekt möglich
geschehen voll machen
aha man den deckel drauf beim beim bei
dem thema design corporate ganz cool was
verschiedene einsätze dankeschön juni
und jetzt schrauben muss darauf achten
was erklären und zwar jemand von euch
vielleicht ein fehler wir machen ein
backpapier über das problem ein
backpapier ist einfach dass die flex
nicht leben bleiben das heißt wirklich
kein backpapier auch nicht einfetten und
möglich einfach jetzt drauf
spitzenzeiten mit screening aufsetzen ja
und zwei mal drücken so
aha sie ist so und jetzt keinen anderen
vornehmen und zwar nehme ich mal habe
ich immer rauchen aufhören sondern macht
ist hier genau das macht auch spaß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er habe gesehen wie die wii einfach
dieses plätzchen gehen jetzt einfach so
in den vorgeheizten backofen einfach
kurz vorher müssen warm ist und dann auf
180 grad maximal neun maximal 1 bis 10
09 19 irgendwo dazwischen liegt
und jetzt muss reinschieben wie gesagt
ohne backbleche und probier mal aus was
wie es ausgeht es wieder rauskommt sagt
haibach und der oberhitze und dann dauer
die neigung ist jetzt vorbei
da gibt es eigentlich nur anerkennen
könnte dass diese plätzchen schon fertig
sind das zeigen wir euch nämlich jetzt
und zwar wenn sich die plätzchen auf dem
backblech einfach verschieben lassen
sagt sagt sagt so da sind sie fertig
jetzt hole ich sie raus und hier waren
beginne schon auf mich wir sind jetzt
ganz ganz ehrlich wir haben zwei fehler
gemacht und zwar die größte fehler den
ich gemacht habe heute war dass er bei
mir dabei war überhaupt und der und der
zweite täter ist folgendes und zwar ich
glaube dass mir einfach zu viel fett
benutzt haben ja nicht ein bisschen
weniger unternehmen können uns an dann
aber fällt es doch gesund ja das ist ja
auch nur okay wir haben zu viel fett
benutzt weil der königin fällt mag ja
und das andere ist wenn man wenn man
diese plötzlichen presse benutzt dann
drückt man nur einmal drauf ist aber
später kennengelernt
später gemerkt dass man wenn er nur
einmal drückt das ist nämlich so aus man
es richtig macht und wenn es falsch
macht oder wie heißt falls sie trotzdem
cool aus dann nicht zu und saison
und natürlich filmes im november das was
man selber gemacht hat ganz schön voll
immer und deswegen haben wir hier jemand
jetzt noch mal eingeladen
da alex eigentlich nicht eingeladen will
da drüben
alle mussten sondern drüben im anderen
zimmer alex kann man kaffee geholt
allerdings kannst du mal diese plätzchen
probieren und uns aber wichtig ehrlich
sagen ob es schmeckt und willst du nicht
wenn du nicht schmecken dann sagt es
echt ehrlich ganz ehrlich also warum wir
jetzt ja auch zum beispiel also wenn sie
schmeckt dann ein ende was dann wäre es
natürlich raus und es war ein echtes
ohne gibt es jetzt aber auch beide kann
man jetzt nicht laufen würde
sei ehrlich nicht schmeckt wenn es
furchtbar schmeckt dann malt er schmeckt
ist für mich persönlich die wogen aber
zu trocken
noch gut
der komplette schokoglasur machen oder
eine schulklasse darüber machen oder man
könnte zb auch in den globus holen
einfach neue kicks bin ich ganz erstmal
abkühlen braucht man ein bisschen heiß
aber zum kaffee zuckerberg habe ich
würde ich das toll gemacht muss ich
sagen ein tolles rezept und jetzt kann
auch sein dass das hier vielleicht ein
paar minuten länger braucht vielleicht
neun oder zehn aber es merkt er jetzt
mit diesem trick einfach schieben gucken
ob sie hängen bleiben
lange gingen so warmen von mit ihr
zusammen hier in der küche zu warten
auch wenn es gelogen ist und ich hoffe
wir machen mal wieder mal es um
einfaches rezept zusammen dann ist das
okay alles läuft in echtzeit und stolz
auf dich macht's gut macht's besser und
ich hoffe ich sehr wir beim kochen und
backen auf geräte die auf geringen geht
schon jetzt kannst es auch so schnell
wie möglich wieder nennt er nicht
ok alles daten ganz gut
[Musik]
wir können auch ich ehrlich sagen das so
gut geschmeckt haben es müssten diesmal
nicht mehr lügen dass es nicht schießen
wenn du was machst du so etwas gutes
heraus kommt ja und niemals gedacht dass
du spritzgebäck hinkriegen und bis gar
nicht so doof wie du aussiehst
dankeschön